et quelle année que de rebondissements
deux changements dans nos quotidiens
dans notre travail aussi certains
secteurs ont souffert plus que d'autres
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
et économique notamment lé pme car vous
allez voir les entreprises du cac 40 ont
allégrement profité de cette crise en
quelques mots les riches sont devenus
encore plus riches alors attention
accrochez vous bien car ce sont des
chiffres qui donnent le tournis alors
que le monde d'avant s'écrouler devant
nos yeux que les suppressions d'emplois
s'enchaîner le patrimoine cumulé des 500
plus grandes fortunes de france a
augmenté de 30% en un an selon le
classement de challenge
le montant de la fortune des 500 plus
riche du pays est désormais à deux mille
milliards d'euros qu'on comptait 95
milliardaire français en 2020 en 2021 la
famille s'agrandit ils sont dorénavant
109 en 2021 pour la cinquième année
consécutive bernard arnault patron de
lvmh est en tête du classement des plus
riches première capitalisation boursière
d'europe avec une fortune estimée à plus
de 157 milliards il est en progression à
57% par rapport à jouer en 2020 arrivent
ensuite la famille hermès avec
81,5 milliards d'euros puis la famille
bettencourt avec
71,4 milliards d'euros des fortunes
poussé par la très forte reprise du
marché du luxe fin 2020 et le rebond des
marchés financiers
mais alors ces chiffres vertigineux sont
ils une bonne chose pour l'économie
française pas vraiment selon
l'organisation attac france les grands
gagnants vont être les actionnaires au
détriment de l'investissement et de
l'emploi on s'attend à un déversement
particulièrement important de dividende
cette année quant à l'enrichissement
français il est en grande partie lié aux
mesures fiscales appliquées ou même
supprimer en france avec par exemple la
transformation de l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune en impôts sur la fortune
immobilière
peu après son arrivée au pouvoir
emmanuel macron
rendement alléger la fiscalité des très
riches cette symbiose avec les patrons
du cac 40 va encore plus loin le
gouvernement a débloqué des aides
publiques massives pour soutenir le
secteur privé pendant la pandémie et les
grandes entreprises du cac 40 en ont
largement bénéficié en connaissance de
cause de l'état et ses aides publiques
sont estimées à 150 5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires en 2020 c'est colossal
et c'est un record en europe des
dizaines de milliards d'euros ont été
versées sans condition sociale fiscale
écologique alors que toutes les
entreprises n'étaient pas forcément dans
le besoin grâce à plusieurs mesures
prévues garantie chômage partiel ou
encore reports de charges beaucoup de
grands groupes comme safran
arcelormittal airbus ou encore renault
ont annoncé une réduction drastique de
leur effectif tout en continuant à
verser des dividendes
l'état est parfaitement au courant de la
bonne forme de ces entreprises puisque
cela se fait avec sa bénédiction
les sociétés dont il est actionnaire
orange et angie par exemple figurent
parmi les distributeurs de dividendes
les plus généreux atos bouygues ou
encore vinci qui ont eu recours au
chômage partiel ont versé des dividendes
en 2020 et 2021 preuve de leur bonne
santé financière et l'évasion fiscale
n'est jamais bien loin
100% des multinationales du cac 40 ont
touché des aides exceptionnelles y
compris celles qui ont versé de généreux
dividendes en 2020 par ailleurs
l'évasion fiscale pratique courante chez
les multinationales est toujours
largement impunie lvmh possèderait ainsi
305 filiales dans les paradis fiscaux et
même si les entreprises du cac 40 sont
en parfaite santé elles ont annoncé 60
2500 suppressions d'emplois dans le
monde depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire dont près de la moitié en
france à titre d'exemple leur fortune
est telle que les bénéfices engrangés
entre mars et décembre 2020 par les 10
hommes les plus riches du monde
suffiraient à financer est la
vaccination de l'ensemble de la
population mondiale